[Music]
I listen I love Jesse James that film is
brilliant what will it take to get that
film released on criterion I don't know
it should be I would really like to see
the long version the first cut that I
saw released on criterion that's what
I'd hoped for can I ask how long that
one was it was over three hours but I
mean I don't think ever will because
Andrew last time I talked to him was
surely some time ago now about it he he
was quite happy with a version that got
released but I still remember that first
the early cut that I saw that was like
three and a quarter I think and I
thought it was no maybe as long at but
it's pretty stunning I was a 4-hour
version the first cut was like four
hours I've seen I have to tell you I
think that he captured something you
together you guys captured something
amazing and I would pay good money to
see any longer version yeah well I think
I agree I mean I think what he got was
the book if you ever read the book a
Hansons book it has that sort of
mythical kind of poetic feeling about it
the feel you know a kind of pecking
power feeling of something passing you
know the world changing and these
characters being kind of left behind by
the world we don't think I'm feeling
myself right now no I refuse to accept
that and but no I think I think he's a
he's a very gifted filmmaker and that
that film just as magic on it